hey guys I'm just it is Tuesday and
here's what's going on in video games
[Music]
first up I've got some free games for
you so long as you already pay for a
PlayStation Plus subscription so free
ish beginning today a total of six games
are available across all platforms with
cross-buy support getting ps4 owners a
total of three games tearaway unfolded
disc jam and lumo disc jam is actually a
new release from high horse
entertainment but it's free for you
immediately so enjoy that one beta
players will be able to pick up seven
and lumo after presumably wiping the
inch of dust from their console and ps3
owners will be able to grab third-person
shooter Earth Defense Force 2025 and
night in birth next up some info on Mass
Effect Andromeda small T player and how
not to play it if that's more your speed
GD o GM Erin Flynn confirmed on Twitter
that there will be DLC maps and they
will be free just like in Mass Effect 3
which received 5 multiplayer expansions
Andromeda also has loot boxes in
multiplayer which players can unlock
through gameplay all by spending
real-world money it's like me your face
scrunches up at the sound of the word
multiplayer because you're a bad loser
and no one wants to play games with you
you can also skip the mode entirely and
still be rewarded for it
producer Fernando Mello is chugging
along on to the 6th day of what he has
dubbed multiplayer mess with the news
that you can send out strike teams from
either single-player or multiplayer to
attempt a mission for a year if they're
successful the AI control team will gain
XP and can level up increasing the
chances of them finishing tougher
missions
if you take on the missions yourself it
appears you'd gain the XP for yourself
as well as some in-game currency that
we're presently a little sketchy on the
details of that one strike team members
are randomly generated and teams will
have different traits which will dictate
the missions they're more likely to
succeed at as a lot of you are quick to
point out in the comments of yesterday's
news the switch has now surpassed the
way as Nintendo's fastest-selling
console in your
and the Americas Nintendo of America
president Reggie fils-aime may told the
New York Times Nick Wingfield that the
console which lets you play Zelda on the
toilet has exceeded the first two day
sales figures in the US for any system
in the company's history the exact added
that the Legend of Zelda breath of the
wild is the best-selling standalone
launch title for a Nintendo platform
ever across the bond in Europe MTV has
reported that the console sold more
units in its launch weekend than any
other piece of Nintendo hardware in the
company's history and breath of the wild
is now Nintendo's best selling launch
title in Europe ever even outselling Wii
Sports its first weekend in other switch
news you can connect your pro controller
and joy cons to your PC via bluetooth
youtube user dre wolf posted two videos
showing the red joy khan and the pro
controller connected to a pc h joy con
despair as an individual controller
however so they can only be used in
their suboptimal
adp deal and scape configuration thanks
to the magic of bluetooth the
controllers can be paired to PC Mac and
Android devices
no iOS support unfortunately because
those devices use a different wireless
specification that's everything I've got
for you today do leave me a comment in
that comment box head to GameSpot for
our coverage on Ghost Recon wildlands
subscribe if you liked the video and
I'll see you tomorrow